scp-173 it's a peculiar statue with a
bad attitude and a penchant for
strangulation and snapping necks though
only if nobody has maintained unbroken
eye contact with it some know it as the
sculpture some know it as the peanut
some know it as probably the most
important anomaly of all considering
it's the one that got this whole crazy
affair started but today we're here to
ask an important question do any of us
really know it at all after all its
original file is hardly comprehensive
you might even venture to say it's one
of the most enigmatic scps out there
despite its popularity but today we're
taking a dive beneath the concrete rebar
and krylon brand spray paint to give you
the real inside scoop on scp-173
we've broken into the scp foundation
archive and found 10 different important
files on this infamous vertebrae vandal
and we're going to explore each and
every one of them with you today as you
can expect from the weird and wild scp
foundation they cover possible pasts
presents and futures and some of them
will naturally contradict but that just
gives you more of an opportunity to
immerse yourself and compare them we
often like to believe that the real
truth is somewhere in between so make
sure you pay attention to every detail
throughout so let's get the show on the
road and explore our 10 documents of
interest for scp-173
in hopes of finally getting the complete
story and of course don't blink document
1 crunch where better to start than the
mind of the sinister sculpture itself
crunch gives us an insight into the
private thoughts of this otherwise
pretty uncommunicative monster and
reveals a great deal about its
relationship with its favorite activity
snapping the necks of anyone who dares
to look away from it in crunch scp-173
speaks in very basic broken
rorschach-esque english saying things
like rule dark
people gone
can move
i
happy
trapped for years
kept by a man for research
left alone in room
left to scratch at walls
left to rot and die unless needed
specimen for research prep by self
never seen by others
never spoken
listen
but never speak
see
but never seen
made of rock when others come
free when they not look
prisoner when they look back
i
hate
scp-173 hates and resents its captors
for keeping it confined in its own mind
crunch how it refers to the snapping of
its victim's neck is the only thing that
gives its life a sense of meaning it
will continue to crunch for as long as
it's contained because thanks to the scp
foundation crunch is all it has left
these days document 2 how 173 got to
site 19. this semi-origin story is one
that the fans of this channel will be
familiar with while it doesn't give us
any insight into why this nasty pile of
concrete actually exists it does inform
us why it's currently our problem
scp-173 isn't actually an anomaly native
to our universe however its native
dimension was destroyed by the beast
trapped in scp-2317
the devourer of worlds as is standard
procedure for a universe about to
experience an xk class end of the world
scenario the foundation's department of
extra-dimensional affairs swooped in and
collected all the valuable anomalies
before the world went down the tube one
of these was of course scp-173
which was vacated to site-19 in our
dimension in 1993.
do you think we would have been better
off if we just left him for the devourer
of worlds to take care of let us know
what you think about that down in the
comments document 3 the black moon
sometimes you can be your own worst
enemy if the file on scp-001 the black
moon is to be believed the scp
foundation may actually be behind the
creation of this ornery objed though in
the foundation's defense it was in
service of potentially fighting off a
far more deadly foe the ominous
extra-dimensional being known only as
the black moon one attempt to stop the
black moon from destroying the universe
was known as the key project which
involved creating a number of items
linked to the black moon via conceptual
engineering that would hopefully nullify
its effects the objects needed the
following qualities an inability to act
while under observation a hostility
towards human life and the capacity to
end conscious life if given the
opportunity those three descriptions fit
scp-173 to a t and it was considered the
project's greatest success however it
sadly wasn't enough to actually stop the
horrific rampage of the black moon the
researcher managing the case dr moto was
so ashamed by the failure that he
willingly entered scp-173's containment
chamber and got his neck snapped in the
process
document 4 conclusions regarding
d173263 incident this document finds its
origins in the video analysis of a
foundation researcher with an incredibly
powerful name dr delano smasher dr
smasher had closely observed video
footage of scp-173 killing several
members of d-class personnel and began
formulating a new theory about how 173
actually killed its victims dr smasher
theorized after all that something with
arms as short as scp-173 and no
opposable digits would have trouble
effectively strangling or snapping human
necks according to dr smasher's
observations
scp-173 doesn't actually make any
physical contact with its victims
instead the victims feel oddly compelled
to look at the creature if ever nothing
is looking at it their eyes will snap
open and their heads will twist at any
angle they need to in order to look at
the creature in the eyes it's the sheer
force of this sudden change that often
leads to snapping necks and bruised
faces for the victims not the sculpture
itself physically causing the damage if
dr smasher is to be believed the
sculpture is deadly purely because it
simply demands to be looked at by
somebody at all times document 5
anniversary this brings us nicely to our
next document anniversary positing a
different theory for the mysterious
creation of scp-173
this comes from the perspective of said
possible creator an anomalous entity
that we'll call the artist much like the
unfortunate dr moto the artist an
intelligent being that can seemingly
become invisible and intangible at will
considered
scp-173 to be its finest creation it
viewed scp-173 as a perfect
representation of humanity it does
nothing but bleed and defecate and if
anyone refuses to pay attention to it it
kills them it was a perfect symbol of
the artist's contempt for humanity it
even easily snuck into site 19 to visit
scp-173 on the anniversary of its
creation and found the foundation's lack
of appreciation for this fine creation
as an act of revenge for keeping his
creation locked up and out of sight for
so long he gave the sculpture permission
just once to kill someone who looked
away even if others were still looking
at it for scp-173 this would be
considered a wonderful little treat
document 6 her masterpiece this next
document known as her masterpiece
suggests that scp-173 was created by a
very different kind of artist while this
potential creator of scp-173 was somehow
able to produce an anomaly she was not
anomalous herself just motivated by rage
and revenge she'd been pregnant in the
past but lost the baby due to the
actions of a man whom she considered her
greatest enemy she vowed to make art
from his demise the woman murdered her
enemy with a baseball bat before using
concrete and rebar to build scp-173
around him almost as a way to mock her
fallen foe however like something out of
a horror movie this act of murderous
creation somehow imbued
scp-173 with life when this spiteful
artist had eventually finished the
creation and started to walk away it
claimed her as its first victim the last
thing she remembered hearing was the
sound of concrete scraping against the
ground and then a nasty crunch before
everything went dark document 7
regarding the statue from one tragedy to
another the document regarding the
statue shows the journey of researcher
marcus silburn from idealistic young
employee to full-on mental breakdown
after trying and failing to gain control
of scp-173
he entered the scp-173 project with
bright eyes and big ideas about how to
contain the sculpture suggesting that
the human element be removed entirely in
order to reduce risk to foundation
personnel he proposed ideas like
introducing a sprinkler and drainage
system to the chamber and using a
sentient ai and remote viewing
technology to keep scp-173 immobilized
however he was then enlightened to some
frustrating and frightening facts about
scp-173
in the absence of actual present human
observation the same buildup of feces
and blood that the creature somehow
excretes builds up in any technology
used to control or contain it it
destroys the circuit boards of ais takes
flying camera drones out of the sky and
even degrades the locks on its chambered
doors leading to the brutal death of a
janitor in the hall researcher silburn
advanced far enough through the ranks of
the foundation to be in direct
communication with dr jack bright the
director of site 19. after his final
attempt at containing the creature
without direct human observation
resulted in a containment breach and the
death of 12 people zilburn was moved off
the scp-173 case after breaking down and
begging for permission to terminate the
anomaly permission was denied dr bright
closed the document with a note to a
member of the o5 council reading it can
be surmised that our conclusion was
correct the object for whatever reason
desires or requires human attention and
will not be denied it document 8 a
chance at freedom we once again returned
to the direct perspective of scp-173
but this differs vastly from the
perspective of scp-173's inner monologue
presented in crunch according to the
document entitled a chance at freedom
scp-173 was actually an incredibly
intelligent agent of espionage sent from
another dimension along with its unknown
cadet though the cadet is heavily
implied to be scp-096
this piece details a containment breach
from scp-173's perspective as it is
shown looking down on humanity and its
primitive technology it laments the fact
that it lost its weapon during the
interdimensional transfer and it seethes
that if it still had its weapon this all
would have played out very differently
despite conceding the fact that it
underestimated the humans which was the
main reason it ended up in containment
it spends the majority of the document
touting its own superiority until one of
the scp-131 the ibots turned up and
froze it in place the degree to which
scp-173 hates the ibots cannot be
overstated document 9 experiences with
scp-682
of course no full story video on scp-173
would be complete without a discussion
of the scp-680 cross tests a number of
researchers though particularly the very
persistent dr carlson decided to use
scp-173 in various manners in hopes of
finally doing in that damn lizard in
their first engagement 682 seemed
rightfully frightened of 173 and when a
sniper shot its eyes out 173 immediately
snapped its neck of course it grew back
a series of sniper proof eyes not long
after someone next suggested scp-173
being sent in with a picture of 096
taped to its chest though this was
rejected as being ridiculous and
incredibly dangerous idea to everyone
thank you dr bryant the researchers then
went after scp-682 with high precision
blades cutting it to pieces each of
which became autonomously dangerous
enemies
scp-173 then began to murder each of
those blobs of the mutated tissue until
it stopped when a d-class was sent in to
stare at it while the rest of 682
regenerated
scp-173 was transported back to its cell
but there was a brief power outage
during transit leading 173 to kill a
number of the staff transporting it this
test was still considered a step in the
right direction after 682 was once again
shrunk by a different anomaly
scp-173 was released into its chamber at
first it appeared that 173 had actually
killed 682 but a week later it returned
having reconstituted itself from matter
that had been splattered on 173 after it
had been brutalized making this test
once again a failure dr carlson
requested the resources to conduct one
more cross test but this request was
denied a member of the o5 council
affixed a request simply saying
stop it carlson please
stop it carlson get some help stop it
carlson document 10 revised entry oh
right the time scp-173 literally caused
an xk class end of the world scenario in
the document revised entry we get a
frightening glimpse into a possible
future world where scp-173 develops a
terrifying new anomalous ability
multiplication we don't know exactly how
it happened but here the sculpture
somehow developed the ability to make
exact copies of itself and what's more
every time one of these copies is
produced the collective scp-173 hive
mind gets stronger allowing them to
think tactically and slowly wipe out
north america even destroying any
potential foundation countermeasures
then ripping and snapping through anyone
or anything that dared opposed in the
end the world decided to take the
nuclear option literally and blow away
north america with nuclear bombardment
in order to stop the scp-173 army from
spreading to the rest of the world and
killing everyone however this attempt
didn't actually work as scp-173s were
spotted in wales over in the uk leading
to a second nuclear bombardment it
continued like this until there were no
human beings left to push the big red
button anymore and only the endless
legions of
scp-173 remained there is one bright
side to this otherwise pretty bleak
situation though a group of around 150
scp-173s ganged up on scp-682 and tore
it to shreds somewhere out there dr
carlson is probably smiling now go check
out scp-173 origin story how 173 got to
site-19 and the ipods
scp-131 for more tales involving the scp
foundation's most psychopathic statue